[Musique]
mais sept visages blancs et triste c ie
vite ce sens dit c'est moi ça a été
il y à 12 ans tom en salle de bain
j'avais tout le succès qu'on peut
imaginer la reconnaissance de mon
employeur déformation importante une
grande maison une belle voiture puis de
l'extérieur
tout allait bien mais à l'intérieur de
moi ma vie étaient tristes et vite sans
émotion je tienne sambi en son be2
travail comment c'est arrivé
dix ans auparavant j'ai commencé avec
une énorme énergie une motivation grande
vous le voir réussir ma vie
professionnelle et au début tout allait
très bien je progressais vite et tout le
monde a dit c'est génial de travailler
avec toi mon expérience mais tu sais
quoi l'année prochaine tu peux faire
encore mieux et bien sûr
je voulais montrer que je peux faire
encore mieux je voulais ni de se voir
mon chef
ma famille et surtout pas moi même alors
je disais oui lui à tous les projets à
tous les opportunités que se présenter
et en conséquence j'ai augmenté mon
temps de travail passant de 10 heures à
12 heures à 14 heures par jour et avec
ça
le stress s'est installé dans mon corps
gentiment lentement il s'est installé et
devenir habituelles et le stress il
n'avait pas seulement un impact ce manga
mais aussi sur le cerveau j'étais dans
une est un instinctif de notre cerveau
dit reptilien de lutte ou fuir pendant
la journée
j'ai lutté contre mes collègues mon chef
mes clientes le soir je fille ma famille
mes amis qui ne comprenaient pas la
grande importance de mon travail c'est
comme ça je suis devenu une somme me
donne encore plus de travail je peux
réussir je peux tout faire
laisse moi faire comment je suis sorti
de ce 1 3 des décisions déménagement des
connexions décision j'ai décidé dans ma
salle de bains que je voulais plus être
700 dit que je voulais être heureux et
souriante que bush je voulais
ivre déménagement à l'époque j'habitais
en suisse alémanique
j'ai parlé autour de moi que je voulais
ou re souriante le nanar
si tu veux être souriant heureux vite
déménager vers les matchs des connexions
déconnexions technologique 6 ans grande
mots parce que qu'est ce que j'ai fait
je pris mon portable le soir je le poser
dans la belle va tuer je fermais la
porte
pourquoi j'avais fait ça parce qu'à
l'époque j'étais incapable de contrôler
ce téléphone le moindre bruit le mans de
vibrations et jeter dessus pour
reprendre à tout les messages et tous
les emails le dernière chose que je fais
et la nuit comme coucher j'ai posé mon
téléphone sur la table de la nuit si je
me réveillais pour peut-être aller faire
pipi
je leurs prix avec ma pour répondre aux
messages pendant la nuit aux américains
et le lendemain c'était la première
chose que j'ai repris des connexions et
avec ses des connexions je suis
gentiment sortie de cette mode de survie
je me rendais compte commente de passer
des heures et des heures au travail
c'est pas ça que notre cerveau produit
le meilleur résultat mais d'havard de
repos d'avoir une vie équilibrée
c'est là notre cerveau il crée des
nouvelles idées innovatrices et c'est
important cette vie équilibrée et mon
téléphone a essayé de faire plusieurs
kandak
il a changé le forme devenu plus sexy
des nouvelles applications et chaque
fois la même réaction
tu restes dans la voiture j'ai commencé
des lieux de livres pour ouvrir mon
esprit des livres sur l'amour la
gentillesse de lâcher prise et j'ai
commencé de faire du yoga et j'ai rien
dis à mes copains parce que je pense
personne n'a envie très pour une soirée
foot et bières et j'ai lu un livre qui
m'a touché il avait une phrase qui dit
si tu aimerais triche faire en sorte que
les autres autour autour de toi le soit
aussi
et c'est mon prof de yoga qui m'a donné
une sacrée leçon de vie
en baissant ses prix de une jour à
l'autre comment tu baisses des prix
juste comme ça pour un homme d'affaires
que je suis
c'était juste inimaginable inimaginable
de juste baisser les prix plus tard je
me trouvais dans les rues de lausanne
faire du karma yoga ça veut dire passer
en action pour les autres alors comme ça
en samedi matin je proposais un marchand
de lui --de et de nettoyer la rue une
fois le marché avait fini nettoyer son
stand alors j'étais la ramasse et
balayer des salades des carottes des
raisins et à la fin j'ai pris tout ça
avec mes proprement pour le ranger plus
le grand monsieur de rome d'affaires met
vraiment en contact avec la vie quand
j'avais fini je disais aux messieurs que
j'avais fini je m'en vais là il
cherchait son portman et je lui dis
monsieur c'était un homme simple geste
pour vous
je veux pas votre argent il me répondait
que dieu vous protège sur votre chemin
de sagesse
ça m'a touché énormément jamais j'ai
entendu des mots comme ça même après une
année de travail très très dur basé sur
cette expérience je voulais amener cette
expérience dans mon mandat faire et j'ai
alors oui c'était dur ah oui c'était dur
je voulais faire des vrais gestes des
vrais gestes des cadeaux à mes clientes
des vrais gestes commerciaux part
augmente au monde prix de une journée de
vente pour cent pour le diminuer le
lendemain de ventes pour son médicament
clients je vous offre un rabais des
vrais gestes et au début mais qui ont
été sources messieurs très suspicieux je
pense certaine pensée il est devenu fou
avec le recul
imaginez vous une homme d'affaires qui
réduit 7 arrive qui ne veut rien en
retour et en plus d'origine allemand ça
c'était juste trop mais avec le temps
les relations songé collaboration est
aujourd'hui quelque chose qui régnait
avec mes clientes et j'ai remarqué aussi
que vouloir être un riche veut pas
seulement dire matériellement riche mais
sont des relations humaines transparente
et honnête spécialement dans le monde
des affaires mais imaginez-vous
autrement je continue à distribuer des
cadeaux à tous mes clientes très vite
mon business model
il arrive à la fin il manque alors une
pièce là dedans il manque une pièce et
cette pièce était que mes clientes c'est
pas quelque chose qui va m'aider mais
moi si j'aimerais être riche
il faut que les autres qui m'entourent
qui sont riches j'ai changé complètement
mon approche
comment ces approches mes clientes comme
angers approche mes collaborateurs
comment ces reproches mais fournisseurs
est aujourd'hui la seule chose que je
veux que contribuer à leur succès je ne
vendent plus rien aimer chiffre
d'affaires sont plus hot que jamais gm
j'ai investi je veux leur succès la même
chose avec les collaborateurs
si on s'entraide
on devient meilleur tous les jours tout
le système devient même meilleur faire
en sorte que les autres sont riches
s'est longtemps que j'avais pas fini
parce que ça m'a rendu heureux de faire
mon business comme ça les choses devient
très facile mais il n'y a pas dans cette
banque d'affaires
elle est agressif et les rapides comment
j'ai fait alors pour vivre tous les
jours
une chose que je fais je le fais aussi
hier soir parce que j'étais stressé par
qu'est-ce qu'il arrive aujourd'hui j'ai
fait un discours je vais faire une bonne
discours vous voulez a inspiré tous les
jours
les dix dernières minutes je prends le
temps avant de m'endormir de dire demain
j'aimerais sourire j'aimerais trop
j'aimerais être une bonne personne et le
lendemain si je me réveille je reprends
ses pensées je construis ma journée sont
de laisser intervenir les médias ou les
réseaux sociaux
je mets propre penser à moi de vous le
voir être heureux et souriante et comme
ça je planifie aussi une journée à la
place à accepter par exemple une rendez
vous à 7 heures le matin
le style en conférence call h et adore
ça si quelqu'un ment vite à cette heure
c'est toujours le même plaisir chez
phase 7 messages avec le texte à cette
heure je suis pas dans la douche soit
vers le petit déjeuner
planifiez votre journée dites vous
qu'est ce que je veux faire cette
journée et comment je veux le faire je
veux le faire
souriante et heureux et quand je suis
dans une bouche on interminables ou à la
devant un ascenseur qui ne veut pas
descendre ou encore en feu rouge qui
veut pas changer à la place de m'agacer
je pense tout pour être heureux et
souriante et à la place de tout faire
vite de vie d'aller au travail de weeds
boire un café de vie peut être faire du
sport de prendre une douche et de vite
encore ajouté une réunion
j'évite de tout faire vite parce qu'avec
toute cette vitesse des erreurs et des
accidents sans vite fait et si quelqu'un
me dit je vais vite aux toilettes
jeudi mais printemps
prends ton temps soit au rheu
[Applaudissements]
avec tout ça je vais pas changer mon
travail je le même poste qu'il ya des
années mon entourage n'a pas changé
c'est pas facile aujourd'hui mais avec
mon approche de vous lever à investir
dans les autres de vouloir être heureux
et souriants tous les jours et c'est ça
qui prennent à la place de critiquer et
des tags à ces critiques et si une chose
je sais pas vous avez vous avez remarqué
si on se retrouve dans une croupe et on
commence à parler très vite en cap
surtout on tape sur les politiciens on
tape sur l'entreprise qui va pas
peut-être encore la famille tout est
négatif
moi j'arrête je participe aussi
certainement si donald trempé dans la
discussion chem aussi j'aime aussi
mais après deux minutes je me dis ça ne
fait pas de bien parce que critiquer les
autres ça fait que mal à nous mêmes mais
montrent le bon exemple qu'est ce que
vous voulez faire là vous restez sur le
chemin de bonheur
moi je retrouvais dans les affaires mon
bonheur et jeu
construit tous les jours et la salle de
bains est pour moi un lieu de vérité et
de réflexion tous les jours je regarde
mon visage et tous les jours je me dis
j'aimerais être souriant des heureux
mais j'ai fait aussi une bilan parce
qu'il ya des joueurs qui sont peut-être
aussi plus lourde que deux autres et
vous vous avez qui vous avez vu qu'
aujourd'hui dans le miroir de votre
salle de bain et qui voulez vous voir
dans le jour dans les années à venir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]